voilà un sujet très cool on va se parler
de dieu on va se parler d'écouteurs de
lg c'est un leurre dernier modèle ci
appelle le town free c'est le fn 7 c'est
ça c'est ce que vous avez ici j'adore ce
modèle parce qu'en plus du town free fn
6 dont je vous ai parlé il ya quelques
jours
celui ci a de la réduction de bruit
active
il ya un peu plus loin on aura une
meilleure autonomie mais garde toujours
l'essence de cette gamme black est super
intéressante parce qu'un confort qui est
vraiment mais vraiment très très bon
dans les oreilles avant de développer
tout ça je vais commencer par vous
montrer un petit peu le produit active
noise cancellation c'est bien ça ça
vient vous couper du monde extérieur on
va regarder dans quelques instants si
c'est vraiment très très cool sa
réduction proactive et surtout elle a ça
que j'adore et que je trouve extrêmement
pertinent un nettoyage aux uv vous avez
des ultraviolets qui viennent éliminé de
99,9 pour cent des bactéries en fait on
vous parle ici des cherry chaque colis
on vous parle ici du staphylocoque doré
lorsque vous le branchez sur le secteur
et uniquement lorsqu'il est branché sur
le secteur vous laisser pendant dix
minutes les petits à cintra dans le
boîtier chargé sur le secteur et ils
vont supprimer 99 9% des bactéries une
fois de plus on parle ici des cherry
chaque colis et du staphylocoque doré
donc ça c'est plutôt cool
vous voyez quand vous l'ouvrez ya une
petite lumière bleue qui apparaît ça
c'est uniquement pour faire beau parce
que les ultra violet on les voit pas en
fait ce qui n'est pas du tout de l'ordre
du visible qu est-ce qu on retrouve
ensuite à l'intérieur donc là ici vous
avez vos petits écouteurs vous venez
ouvrir sa tac vous retrouvez ensuite ici
outils câble port charge pour venir
charger en usb usb c'est vous avez des
embouts en silicone ya trois tailles
différentes c'est basique et ça marche
bien ce qui nous intéresse c'est ça
c'est le petit bois car le petit boîtier
parce que j'avais déjà tout de suite
c'est cette forme de galet qui tient
vraiment vraiment bien en main vous
mettez dans une poche très facilement
recharge en usb c'est vous avez un petit
voyons ici lorsque vous le branchez sur
le secteur qui vous marque vous avez le
nettoyage qui se fait grâce aux
ultraviolets donc ça c'est cool
et lorsque vous l'ouvrez surtout vous
découvrez ici ces petits écouteurs très
sympa et vous le marquis cia partenariat
avec méridian mairie
genk est une entreprise anglaise qui est
spécialisée dans l'eau de bio tellement
d'années qui venait leur sont
extrêmement bonne qualité donc ça s'est
très très bien et sur tout ce que j'aime
vraiment bien avec ses produits alors au
delà de la forme qui est vraiment plutôt
sympa bien aussi que j'aime bien
l'esthétique vous l'avais déjà dit sur
les fn 6 sur les fn 16 c'est
sensiblement la même chose mais moi le
truc que m'avait vraiment surpris
lorsque j'ai essayé le fn 6 et qui se
confirme une fois de plus avec les fn 7
c'est le confort vous les mettez c'est
extrêmement agréable voulait positionner
voulait tourner les charmants comme ça
regardez vous prenez vous voulez tourner
ça se positionne extrêmement facilement
le confort et là vous pouvez bouger la
tête ça ne bouge pas pour tous les ed
banger vous avez vraiment de quoi faire
j'aime beaucoup
voilà j'aime beaucoup d'expérience la
grosse différence vous allez retrouver
ici entre la rn6 et les fn 7 c'est la
réduction de bruit actif parce que vous
avez exactement les mêmes transducteurs
à l'intérieur vous avez la même
fabrication vous avez la même batterie
tout est pareil
la vraie grosse différence que vous
allez retrouver entre les deux c'est la
réduction de bruit active l'expérience
audio est globalement bonne on va pas
avoir ici des grosses basses qui
ronronne on va venir s'appuyer sur un
des co leaders dans l'application
messages vous le monde dans quelques
instants on n'a pas un spectre qui est
complètement l'âge mais du fait d'avoir
cette application est équaliseur on peut
venir corriger tout ça vous avez si de
bord dynamiques de 6 mm et la différence
que vous allez avoir entre les fans si
c'est l'effet ne s'est d'ailleurs je
vous invite à lire mon test des fn 6
comme ça vous saurez tout c'est qu'ici
grâce à quelques différences de
fabrication au niveau du procédé et bien
vous allez récupérer un peu plus de
basses mais là où on gagne plus de
basses c'est grâce à la réduction de
bruit active et ça je vous explique dans
quelques instants ce produit là il ya
aussi quelques limites ici on est
uniquement de codecs on a dû a assez et
du sbc pas d'app et ex pas d'app et
ex-agent des tongs en terme de place de
fréquences on va pas venir pousser
extrêmement large
on est ici sont des écouteurs qui coûte
199 99 vous pouvez trouver d'ailleurs
moins cher en ce moment il ya quelques
promos je vous mets les liens en bas
dans la description qu'on peut trouver
en tout 150 euros donc pour 150 euros
pour moi avec la réduction proactive
ici le taf effet votre application elle
se situe juste ici c'est la tonne
fripouille au niveau de batterie si je
suis à 100% c'est très très bien et vous
voyons plus ici l'écho à l'isr et ça
c'est un truc que j'aime beaucoup ce
trouve vraiment très très très
pertinente à l'heure où des pouvoirs
bien changé par défaut vous êtes en
immersif immersif c'est bien les choses
c'est un petit peu médium regarder
vraiment un spectre médium et vous
manqué un petit peu de rondeur vous avez
le base moustiques qui va venir ajouter
du corps qui apportait beaucoup plus de
rondeur pour ça s'est super bien après
vous avez naturel et river le bout
vous pouvez venir customiser civaux
équaliseur alors moi je le conseille
vraiment quand je vous parlais des fn 6
devenir customiser vos équaliseur pour
moi c'était très très très important ici
ce que je vous conseille c'est de venir
sur le bass boost qui vous apporte de la
clarté au niveau de la voix vous n'avez
pas je vous dis une fois de plus 2 par
les collègues que vous avez ici parce qu
on est en blue tooth sont issus du
bluetooth 5.0 et bien vous n'allez pas
avoir un spectre avec un son très aiguë
très très faim on reste quand même dans
une plage médium médium grave médias
mais guy avec le basbous vous récupérez
un petit peu plus de rondeur d'aller
chercher des fréquences un peu plus
basse mais vous n'allez pas non plus
avoir un truc avec un spike qui est
complètement dingue ça il faut le savoir
ce que j'aime dans cette application
c'est que vous êtes pouvoir dire
paramétrer si votre pavé tactile parce
que oui oui oui là dessus vous avez un
pavé tactile qui est situé juste ici ça
c'est un très très très gros point
positif de l'expérience vous appuyer une
fois plaît vous appuyer une fois posée
surtout vous voulez tout paramétrer dans
votre application c'est vous qui
choisissez comment vont être paramétré
ses boutons là par exemple génère
paramétrage appuyer une fois gauche
commandes vocales
ici je suis sur ios et donc syrie
comment droite lecture à réappuyer deux
fois à gauche diminuer le volume de foi
droite augmenter le volume 3 fois à
gauche
dans son précédent trois fois à droite
morceau suivant et j'appuie sur
n'importe quel jeu peut venir choisir
entre lecture arrêt commandes vocales
augmenter le volume diminue et volume
précédent suivant ou alors rien du tout
ça
j'aimais beaucoup sur la rn6 j'aime
beaucoup également sur ce modèle là il
ya un autre truc qui est intéressant
qu'on n'avait pas sur la rn6 comme je le
dis c'est la réduction de bruit active
est bien ici vous avez un truc vachement
cool sa place que vous avez votre
écouteurs vous faites un appui long et
le puy l'on va venir
switcher entre un mode transparence
entre la réduction de bruit active ou
alors carrément vous couper tout ça pour
trouver ici le contrôle de son ambiant
et de la haine c'est à ncc active noise
cancelling c'est la réduction de bruit
active
là vous voyez qu'il est sûre l'ont donc
là j'ai aucune réduction de bruit tu
peux passer ici en sons ambiants qui va
venir amplifier les cendres l'extérieur
et ensuite parce en réduction de bruit
active
je peux le faire exactement de la même
manière garder après je me mets un
écouteur tu fais un appui long europe je
change je passe en sons ambiants jusqu'à
un autre appui long hop et je passe ici
on ne risque en soling donc voyez c'est
très simple très intuitif et tout se
trouve dans l'application alors avant de
vous parler juste en du résultat de
cette réduction de bruit active des
différents modes on va regarder
l'application un poil plus en détail bon
niveau de volume ok verrouillage du pavé
tactile si vous le souhaitez
why not vous avez si un tri intelligent
bon il ya quelques petites
fonctionnalités qui sont plutôt cool ce
qui est vraiment important pour moi ici
c'est toute la réduction de bruit c'est
toute la gestion paramétrage de vos
boutons de mise à jour logicielle bien
évidemment trouver vos écouteurs si vous
avez perdu
eh bien vous les faites sonner l'un et
l'autre donc ça c'est très très cool on
retrouve ici l'essentiel dans cette
application mais ça marche et ça c'est
très très précis c'est très couvert
maintenant on va parler de la réduction
bruit active parce que c'est un point
extrêmement important c'est vraiment la
grosse différence qu'on a en trop les
effets de 6 et les fn 7 il ya une
différence de prix entre les deux
modèles mais c'est surtout une
différence au niveau de la technologie
déjà avec les frenchies vous avez une
réduction de bruit passive c'est-à-dire
que vaut un travail bush et vos oreilles
comme si vous mettiez vaudois dans vos
oreilles ici vous avez une réduction
bruit active donc on essaie de quelque
chose de 100 % numérique pour arriver à
ça il a fallu rajouter des micros sur le
fn 6 vous aviez deux micros en tout et
pour tout parent écouteurs un micro
extérieur un micro intérieur ici vous
avez trois micros en avait un qui va se
trouver sur le o 1 sur le bas et un à
l'intérieur ils vont servir pour la
réduction voltige pour capter les sons
extérieurs mais également pour réduire
les colorer vos appels téléphoniques
appels téléphoniques qui marche très
bien très bonne qualité on entend bien
vous et bien entendu ça aussi ça marche
bien et c'est cool ici lg vous annonce
que la réduction collective est optimisé
pour les hautes fréquences pour tout ce
qui va être bruits urbains notamment des
bruits dans un café des personnes qui
parlent dans une salle vous cache pas
qu'en ce moment avec le co vide c'est un
peu compliqué d'aller écouter le bruit
dans un café moi ce que je remarque ici
c'est que la réduction de bruit elle est
pas mauvaise mais elle va pas aussi loin
que ce qu'on peut retrouver chez
certains concurrents va un peu plus loin
que la réduction de bruit passive
par contre un truc que je trouve très
intéressant je sais pas d'où ça vient
d'un point de vue logiciel est ce que
c'est un petit bug je sais vraiment pas
d'où ça vient
mais lorsque vous activez la réduction
de bruit passive
vous récupérez des basses mais vous
récupérez vraiment des bases d'un coup
c'est assez bluffant
je me suis mis en mode bass boost
normalement j'ai des basses j'ai
désactivé la réduction proactive alors
je me suis mis en mode transparent et
bien je perde un peu de basses et
lorsque je me mets en réduction de bruit
active je récupère des basses mais
vraiment mais vraiment ça me fait
ronronner davantage donc ça c'est assez
marrant le mode sont bien je le trouve
pas complètement dingos on va
effectivement entendre un petit peu ce
qui se passe en dehors que le son qui
est capté par nos micros
va être réinjectés à l'intérieur de nos
intra pour vous puissiez entendre ce qui
se passe on va récupérer quelques
fréquences médium ça va vous en donner
un peu plus en vous en donnez trop si
par exemple vous vous parlez eh bien
vous entendez avec un mode transparent
à vous entendre ce que votre voix soient
réinjectées ici c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup le cas je m'entends pas
énormément
j'entends un peu plus je peux être un
peu plus attentif à ce qui se passe
autour de moi mais il faudrait venir
injecté un peu plus de son coude ce soir
réellement pertinent donc pour moi il ya
quelques petits points de bémol là
dessus sur la partie réduction de bruit
et sur la partie sons ambiants
transparent ce qu'il est plutôt bien et
si au niveau des écouteurs c'est que
vous avez certification ipx4 donc
résistant à l'eau et à la sueur comme
ils ont une très très bonne tenue vous
pouvez les prendre pour aller courir
allez vous amuser faire du sport ce que
vous voulez ils vont pas tomber de votre
tête vous pouvez pogoter vous faire le
ed banger pendant des heures ça ira très
très bas donc ça c'est bien et si vous
avez uniquement vos intra qui sont ipx4
mais pas votre boîtier il faut le savoir
nous avaient pas mettre le boîtier dans
l'eau pour trouver aussi vous assistant
vocaux et si notamment comme sur ios je
pouvoir retrouver syrie vous avez
également google assistant puisque ils
sont compatibles ios mais également
android donc ça c'est aussi une très
bonne nouvelle
l'autonomie sera meilleure par rapport
au fn 6 au lieu d'arriver jusqu'à 18h
vous arriver jusqu'à 21h pour voir qu on
a exactement la même chose d'un point de
vue matériel année tu as qu'une batterie
de 390 millions terreur et 55 millions
père heures par un train on va donc
gagner une heure par écouteurs on passe
de six à sept heures entre le fn 6 et le
fn 7
on a toujours de la recharge rapide vous
le charger à 5 minutes vous gagnez une
heure d'écouté et vous avez toujours de
la recharge sans fil avec votre boîtier
ça c'est bien noter ici que la recharge
sans fil ne vous permettra pas d'avoir
le nettoyage par ultraviolets c'est
uniquement sur la charge filaire ça je
voulais dit mais je tiens quand même à
préciser
autre point qui est bien et qui me
semble aujourd'hui être un grand
classique sur des produits comme celui
là c'est que lorsque vous le mettez dans
vos oreilles et bien d'une détection
automatique
ils savent qu'ils sont là ils viennent
donc lancé et la musique directement
merci beaucoup tu peux t'arrêter
je vous parlais avec la musique de
l'oreille c'est un petit peu difficile
ça a produit que je trouve plutôt
intéressant j'aurais aimé que lg
un peu plus loin avec d'autres codecs
pour venir élargir le son pour qu'on
aille plus loin au niveau de cette
qualité audio pour moi ici le premier
très gros point positif c'est le confort
ils sont super super super super
confortable
c'est l'expérience avec vos boutons vous
switchez très facilement vous paramétrez
tout très facilement l'expérience au
niveau de l'application est aussi
vraiment superbe
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en barrant commentaire est ce que
vous avez acheté les f-16 de lg qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cfm set est-ce que
vous
les trouvais intéressant est ce que vous
aimez bien l'idée effectivement d'avoir
des petits écouteurs qui vont venir
supprimer 99 9% des bactéries
escherichia coli
c'est un philologue doré qu'est ce que
vous pensez de lg au niveau de la partie
audio est ce que vous avez déjà écouté
pas écouté en tout cas moi je vous
invite à venir les découvrir vous ai mis
un lien en bas dans la description dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en barrant
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler de
teck des gros bisous dekker qui et
prenez soin de vous ciao